und bei gericht ist für uns jessica
verleih mir nun auch live zugeschaltet
das kleinkind ist gestorben zwei
menschen haben knapp überlebt was wissen
wir über den täter von frankfurt am main
ihr habt die eier ist 41 jahre alt und
lebte 13 jahre in der schweiz in zürich
reiste 2006 erlaubt ein und beantragte
dann dort asyl was in 2008 gewährt wurde
er galt als zuverlässig und fleißig
arbeitet dort als bauschlosser hat
selbst drei kinder und eine frau gegen
im jahr 2017 ungefähr verlor er dann
seinen job macht ein
integrationsprogramm mit und dann erst
2019 im januar begann ist dass er zum
ersten mal mit psychischen problemen von
einem arzt krankgeschrieben wurde
und genau in diesem jahr 2009 10 kam es
auch zum ersten ausbruch häuslicher
gewalt da später nämlich seine frau und
seine drei kinder im keller ein und
machte sich damit mitte juli auf den weg
mit dem zug von basel nach frankfurt er
ist jetzt in untersuchungshaft 2009 10
nach dem vermissten august weil er als
schizophrene eingestuft wird und einige
schafe allgemein sollte beginnt also der
prozess gegen ihn
was steht vor einem jetzt am ersten tag
auf dem kleinen was wird erwartet der
mann muss zunächst einmal klären ist er
überhaupt schuldfähig ja könnte wegen
mordes verurteilt werden und wegen
versuchten mordes dies aber nur wenn im
heimtücke vor gewährten werden kann
ein bisschen gutachten jetzt aber ein
unsere schuldunfähig ist da und er soll
stimmen hören oder verfolgung amt jagen
er sagt selber dass handystrahlen und
elektromagnetische wellen in steuern und
beeinflussten und deshalb muss man jetzt
schauen in welche richtung das geht eine
dauerhafte unternehmen hat sich früh ist
aber sehr wahrscheinlich haben sich die
angehörigen der opfer bereits geäußert
was sie jetzt von diesem prozess
erwarten also die angehörigen selbst
wenn die nicht vor ort heute hier weil
diesen prozess weil es für sie
unerträglich ist das ganze ist ein sehr
sehr schwerer schicksalsschlag für sie
und sie wollen vor allem die eltern und
auch die schwester von leo möchten vor
allem eins und zwei antworten auf fragen
sie wollen ganz genau wissen und
verstehen was passiert
wollen alle hintergründe und alle
details zum paten stand wir sind heute
beantworten möchten